je demande donc à l'assemblée de se
prononcer par un seul vote sur l'article
3 à l'exclusion de tout amendement
[Musique]
ça vient de considérer les droits des
handicapés les droits de l'homme c'est
très insultant d'être uniquement comme
un poids et de se sentir en plus
uniquement comme un point
[Musique]
on était très content au début de voir
qu'il y avait des députés qui soutenez
nos idéaux qui sort qui amenait des
arguments très intéressant mais on a été
vraiment super déçu quand vint le vote a
été bloqué parce que surtout qu'on
savait pas que c'était possible
donc ça nous a paru super
anticonstitutionnelle et à briser tous
nos espoirs de pouvoir vivre en couple
ensemble dans le même endroit avait
espéré pouvoir peut-être vivre ensemble
se marier plus tard juste se pacser
[Musique]
je vais devoir toujours habité près de
ses parents près de chez ses parents
pour qu'elle garde son revenu et qu' on
puisse se voir souvent et en tant que
jeune c'est quand même assez respectifs
de devoir rester absolument chez ses
parents xi a été amené à mener à vivre
avec moi actuellement je suis stagiaire
et je touche le 1600 rouge beaucoup de
chance et ça ferait qu elle aimerait que
50% de 2 c de son revenu si par contre
j'étais dans la vie active par un
ingénieur comment on pourrait s'attendre
à avoir 2000 euros par mois
donc elle aurait pu dû tout dh on aurait
de 1000 euros pour nous deux points
couple de jeunes dont une handicapée
donc tu auras besoin de de soins
particuliers c'est pas assez
[Musique]
ça pose plein de risques notamment par
rapport aux violences conjugales on voit
bien que les femmes en situation de
handicap sont ils semblent 50% + plus
propice à à subir des violences
conjugale et sexuelle
ça crée une situation de dépendance
totale du conjoint qui est super
dangereuse
[Musique]
il y as je suis sûr qu'à des centaines
de couples des milliers de couples qui
ne qui ne partage absolument pas leurs
revenus et qui sont très heureux qu'ils
sont très sains c'est dommage de pas
laisser ce soin aux personnes
handicapées de vivre dans le modèle de
couples qui désirent